[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler gilles voyer
oratrice nationale de la france
insoumise fatima il ya dani secrétaire
national adjoint du parti socialiste
docteur en virologie également ainsi que
joëlle mélin députée européenne
rassemblement national bonsoir mesdames
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france un mot donc sur ce rapprochement
des allemands avec les russes pour des
pré commandes de doses technique ça se
précise ce soir puisque la russie fait
savoir qu'elle a débuté officiellement
les discussions avec berlin pour la
bande de ce vaccin les allemands qu'ils
raison d'anticiper fatima ya dani moi je
pense que moi je suis ni pro européenne
mais je pense que les amener en fait les
décisions et surtout en fait les choix
qui sont faits doivent être soumis à
l'autorité européenne et notamment à l'
agence du médicament européenne si elle
délivre les autorisations et ensuite
elles sont validées par les
autorisations nationales pour l'instant
c'est c'est ce qui a été fait dans ce
sens pour l'ensemble des candidats
vaccins dans le pays moi je pense que il
est essentiel en fait de d'échanger de
discuter donc sur avec l'ensemble des
pays dans l'union européenne
si chacun y va de soi je crois qu on est
sur une démarche plutôt concurrentiel
alors que l'intérêt c'est d'essayer de
vacciner le plus massivement l'ensemble
des pays du monde et je pense pas que ce
soit la meilleure démarche que diaby
chacun tout seul pour négocier alors
dans le même temps c'est le cas de le
dire quand certains traînent des pieds
qui a urgence il faut peut-être prendre
des discussions est ce que peut-être
joëlle mélin bouquet au coeur du
réacteur puisque je le rappelle cette
députée européenne est ce que les
allemands anticipe également peut-être
ce nouveau retarder des livraisons et
sont tout simplement pragmatique parce
que y aura duré tard et donc une pénurie
de vaccins en europe mais ils sont
pragmatiques et ils ont tout à fait
raison
parce que je comprends les raisons de ma
consoeur qui et européiste
mais il se trouve que dans la mesure où
sauf erreur de ma part le procédé qui
est utilisé pour le vase passe uniques
c'est à dire des ruches différents dans
le deux élections et ta processus
parfaitement connu et que dès lors il
n'a pas à passer par une procédure
obligatoire de l'ema nous pouvons au
niveau national parfaitement donné une
autorisation
dans l'état actuel des choses madame
peut-être sauf erreur de ma part mais
dans l'état actuel des choses nous
n'avons aucune donnée moderne éclairé de
la science qui nous autorise à refuser
ou accepter sur des critères qu'ils
soient des critères de l'ontt
il faut actuellement avancé alors soit
on est pour la vaccination et ne la
retarde ont pas anticipons exactement
comme les allemands les tchèques les la
slovénie ou maintenant peut-être
l'autriche anticipons anticipons ne
serait ce qu'avec des préachats ça nous
évitera les boulettes énorme disons le
camp même s'ils ont été commises par la
commission européenne dans leur hâte et
absolu des précommandes et des prêts à
chaque bloc maintenant tout le monde par
ces fameux cinq contrats ou alors on
n'est pas pour la vaccination mais à ce
moment là que l'union européenne demande
instamment à tous ceux qui ont fait des
recherches sur des recherches diagnostic
soit des recherches thérapeutiques avec
des fonds européens sur des procédés
autre que la vaccination de sortir enfin
ses études
je sais moi j'ai rencontré des start up
qui ont mis au point avec des fonds
européens des méthodes diagnostiques
elles ne sont toujours pas agréé peu
importe peu ce sont déjà au moins
désagréments temporaires
nous sommes actuellement éventuellement
dans la perte de chance et la source de
traitement que l'on appelle
compassionnel donc il faut urgemment
faire comme les allemands alors c'est
vrai que on attend cet avis de l'ema pas
avant fin juin nous at on prévenu
comment jean royer vous expliquer parce
que madame joëlle mélin on nous parle de
lenteurs administratives
jean luc mélenchon le chef de votre
parti la france a soumis ce but parle
plutôt d'idéologie puisque les français
en tout cas le gouvernement français et
que je la russie de faire des vaccins un
outil de propagande dans le monde et il
va trop loin quand on dit ça jean yves
le drian on fait vraiment des idéologies
en france avec ce vaccin
non je crois qu'on fait on fait de
l'idéologie ce qu'ils vaccinent le mieux
aujourd'hui en europe c'est la serbie
qui a utilisé le vaccin russe et chinois
et la hongrie qui utilise aussi le
vaccin bus et nous on s'est
volontairement limité un petit nombre de
vaccins pour des raisons idéologiques
apparemment notre gouvernement croit
encore que que la russie et est
communiste donc il faudrait utiliser
absolument tous les vaccins qui sont
disponibles vaccin russe le vaccin
chinois le vaccin cubain qui est aussi
disponible sur le marché
il ya même plusieurs vaccins cubains qui
sont disponibles et au lieu de ça on
s'en n'est pas donné les moyens mêmes on
s'est pas donné les moyens d'avoir en
grande quantité les vaccins les vaccins
qu'on utilise déjà puisque on n'organise
pas la production de masse et qu'on
laisse les laboratoires faire comme ils
l'entendent pour préserver leurs profits
notamment en refusant de lever les
brevets concrètement aujourd'hui il
faudrait lever les brevets sur sur sur
les vaccins josé passe tout le monde se
rend compte de ce que ça veut dire mais
les brevets c'est une règle de main de
marché qui dit qu'une entreprise quand
elle a inventé quelque chose pendant
quelques années est la seule à pouvoir
avoir le droit de la vente est
aujourd'hui en situation de crise c'est
pas comme ça qui font fonctionner il
faut pas tenir compte de règles pareil
qui valent le reste du temps et il faut
que tout le monde produisent partout où
c'est possible il faut réquisitionner
l'industrie pharmaceutique est pas
attendre gentiment que les labos veulent
bien organiser progressivement la montée
de la production fait il ya des nids sur
cette analyse est ce que vous êtes
d'accord comment vous expliquez on l'a
compris nous est très pro européens et
voilà c'est certainement une bonne chose
mais enfin en attendant on n'arrive pas
à se mettre d'accord on a peut-être fait
les mauvais choix
pariez sur les mauvais
axe 1 que faut-il faire maintenant selon
vous on a beau défendre l'europe
comment on agit dans l'urgence
maintenant je crois que je veux juste
revenir sur les propos qui viennent
d'être qu'il y a des traits non c'est
moi je partage complètement le fait
qu'il s'agit de suspendre les brevets
parce que si on veut vacciner
massivement en fait il faut suspendre
les projets et permettre à chacune et
chacun de pouvoir produire de pouvoir
produire massivement pour vacciner
massivement là on est en train
d'organiser une concurrence entre les
pays les plus riches et les pays les
moins riches pour l'accès à la
vaccination à l'accès au vaccin est
juste rappeler quand même que ces
vaccins n'aurait jamais vu le jour
s'il n'y avait pas eu des fonds publics
parce que c'est grâce aux fonds publics
que le virus a pu être séquencés qu'on a
pu obtenir justement des vaccins qui ont
été basées sur ces séquences et je crois
que en fait notre vraie combat au lieu
d'essayer d'expliquer que c'est un
problème de diplomatie avec un certain
nombre de vaccins note vrai combat il
est de défendre le fait que le vaccin
deviendra bien mondiale et de libérer
les brevets pour permettre justement la
production en masse sur l'ensemble du
territoire et permettre d'irriguer
l'ensemble des quatre coins de la
planète avec les vaccins juste rappeler
quand même que si la vaccination ne
concerne qu'un petit nombre de pays et
que certains ne sont pas certaines
populations ne sont pas vaccinés on le
virus en ne disparaissant pas où au
moins on ne diminuant pas va revenir
sous une forme ou sous une autre est
notamment sous la forme de variants qui
risquent d'échapper aux vaccins on a
actuellement
donc c'est non seulement préserver la
santé de tout le monde
mais d'abord préserver notre santé que
de permettre à l'ensemble de la
population mondiale d'être vacciné je
crois que notre premier combat il est de
libérer les brevets vous êtes d'accord
joëlle mélin avec ce débat qui est de
plus en plus fréquent cette libération
des brevets c'est une idée que vous
jugez trop communiste pour moi elle
n'est pas spécialement communiste c'est
une idée qui peut se poser pour autant
comme disait ma consoeur tout à l'heure
que l'on et de la recherche publique
or en france depuis maintenant 40 ans la
recherche publique est complètement
indigente
en conséquence on est obligé de faire
appel au privé
vous pouvez pas demander au privé quand
même de faire de la philanthropie à 300%
alors j'entends bien le problème de l'
urgence de centre pandémie mais chose
rappeler quand même que le problème de
base c'est pas tant le brevet ou pas le
brevet c'est cette mondialisation
entièrement voulue par l'europe je
permets de vous le rappeler madame cette
mondialisation qui a éclaté les sites de
production et qui font que maintenant
nous sommes en pénurie soit de matières
premières soit d'excipients soit de
toutes les matières plastiques
nécessaire pour faire les filtres ou les
poches qui permette l'incubation des
virus et que si aujourd'hui monsieur
breton nous dit à 55 sites de production
ce n'est pas vrai il y à 55 lieu de
production éclatée pour cinq à six
vaccins et l'europe est grande et très
largement trop grande
d'ailleurs pour avoir une logistique qui
soit acceptable dans l'état actuel des
choses et que dire de la logistique qui
fait que la russie s'appuie sur l'inde
qui s'appuie aussi sur la chine qui
s'appuie sur d'autres pays dans le monde
l'urgence des urgences ça va être de
rationaliser cette production de revenir
à une relocalisation autant que faire ce
peuple il est illusoire de vouloir dire
on va mettre ça dans un seul pays
la chaîne est beaucoup trop longue et
beaucoup trop complexe de la matière
première à la logistique le stockage et
le et toutes les formes de de production
et des chaînes de l'état actuel des
choses c'est aussi une énorme erreur de
là
de la commission européenne et qui a
fait ses prêts achats qui ont fait que
beaucoup de l'amo pas les grands labos à
l'écran lead mais des start-up appuyé
sur des grands labos producteurs ont
entendu d'avoir l'argent pour augmenter
leur chaîne de production
évidemment les promesses de novembre
décembre et janvier n'était pas tenable
donc que oui à un moment donné il y est
ce qu'on appelle mesdames un bien commun
cela s'entend je peux parfaitement le
comprendre mais aussi ça ne réglera rien
du tout des anomalies de la
mondialisation et des anomalies de
l'union européenne et je ne parle pas de
l'attitude totalement chaotique et à
contre-courant du gouvernement dacron
qui là est vraiment un objet
d'anthologie quand on se retournera dans
l'histoire ce sera vraiment un cas
d'école j'ai le royer votre votre
réaction à ces propos de joëlle mélin
j'ai l'impression que là on est un peu
face à deux positions idéologiques si
vous voulez il y en a une pour qui le
problème ne peut pas être l'europe et
celle uniquement les brevets et l'autre
pour qui le problème c'est l'europe mais
il faut quand même pas trop remettre en
question les brevets et pas demander aux
labos de faire de la philanthropie ben
simon devant nos labos de rendre ce qui
l'argent public on leur a donné les
peuples du monde entier ont contribué au
total pour l'équivalent de 10 milliards
d'argent public
halla halla halla production de ces
vaccins et pfizer aujourd'hui prévoit 15
milliards de dollars de profits avec 30%
de marge
donc le problème c'est les deux c'est à
la fois cette question des brevets il
faut libérer les brevets il ya cinquante
pays qui l'on demandait à l'om c'est et
là dessus sur sur le gouvernement macron
à la france a voté non à l'organisation
mondiale du commerce sur le fait de
libérer les brevets mais néanmoins tant
que c'est pas fait il faut pas se
remettre entre les mains de l'europe et
et sam en réduira sa stratégie absurde
de se limiter aux vaccins américain et
puisqu'on parle de sous un parmi les
réactions politiques aujourd'hui on a vu
celle de jean luc mélenchon tout à
l'heure marine le pen s'est aussi
exprimé un message un petit peu mais
l'issue de la patronne du rassemblement
national
pourquoi l'europe et donc la france
boycott tel le vaccin ce public tu es
russe trop efficaces ou bien trop bon
marché
ce taux est à un piqué notre curiosité
convient pas et l'union européenne ses
vaccins c'est vrai qu'on sait que les
prix sont différents mais on ne sait pas
combien je vous propose de regarder
astrazeneca de dollars 19 ça va
s'afficher sur notre écran dans quelques
instants james n85 pic 9.95 un dollar
toujours cavaco 11,84 pfizer biotech est
l'un des vaccins les plus plébiscités en
europe 14,7 dollar et moderne à 18
dollars donc vous voyez que les prix ne
sont pas les mêmes
c'est vrai que voilà c'est moins cher
pour contre notamment moitié prix du
moderna c'est ce qui peut bloquer jor-el
à un mail 1 je ne suis pas sûr vous
savez j'ai eu l'occasion de consulter je
fais faire une étude d'ailleurs sur les
contrats ces contrats sont tellement à
plus de 60 % non consultables puisque
complètement biffé qui lie à toutes
sortes de clauses que l'on ne connaît
pas et bien sûr que le prix est une est
un élément parmi tant d'autres mais si
c'est celui là qui fait qu' on retarde
la vaccination ça c'est tout à fait
inadmissible après vous savez très bien
que le préachat été fait par l'europe
mais que sont les états qui payent donc
là les notions de tarifs seraient
discutées au niveau des états et encore
faudra-t-il que cela ne soit pas
entachée d'indemnités en cas de vous le
savez les laboratoires qui demandent des
indemnités
lorsqu'il y a des des ruptures de
contrats partiel ou des difficultés de
logistique
fatima ya dani vous qui nous avez parlé
voilà de votre attachement à l'europe et
à l'unité dans ces négociations et
surtout dans dans l'action quand vous
entendez cette députée européenne nous
dire que les contrats sur les vaccins
sont totalement opaques ainsi pas la
seule à nous le dire il est quasiment
impossible de les consulter dans le
thain quelle est votre réaction vous
trouvez ça normal que les élus européens
n'est pas accès à ces contrats non non
pas du tout pas du tout normal de ne pas
y avoir accès d'autant qu'il est
important de savoir comme vous l'avez
dit le prix les différentes clauses
contractuelles pour ces contrats et bien
évidemment il s'agit de faire la
transparence sur tous ses contrats et un
grand nombre de députés européens l'ont
demandée et malheureusement vous l'avez
souligné c'est pas le cas
jean royer joue votre sentiment sur
cette opacité ça veut dire que on nous
cache des choses ou tout simplement
voilà c'est un hasard qu'on ne puisse
pas comme ça voire les contrats ça nous
regarde pas finalement c'est la méthode
classique de l'union européenne dès
qu'il ya des choses à négocier
effectivement c'est de considérer que
pour c'est pour que ces négociations se
déroulent correctement elle doit se
dérouler dans le plus grand des secrets
et donc y compris les parlementaires
européens ne doivent pas avoir accès à
ces contrats et ne doivent pas pouvoir
les consulter mais c'est la méthode
classique de l'union européenne qui est
de considérer que le contrôle
démocratique sur les décisions qu'elle
prend n'est pas indispensable qu'elle
peut son passé que les fonctionnaires de
l'union de l'union européenne que la
commission européenne va faire au mieux
et que on n'a pas besoin de leur
vérifier qu'il faut simplement leur
faire confiance
on le disait joëlle mélin agence
européenne du médicament qui va
d'ailleurs devoir délibéré priori fin
juin sur le spo coût élevé et ton
absolument certain
son indépendance totale écoutez son
indépendance on veut essayer d'y croire
par courtoisie mais le temps laissé
autant de temps puisque le laboratoire
russe a présenté sa demande je crois le
3 mars quatre mois pour la réponse quand
il y a urgence
tout laisse à penser la collègue
virologues je pense pourra dire encore
mieux que moi que si nous sommes bien
dans ce qui est dit à savoir des vagues
de virus différent puisque ayant muté
l'épidémie s'éteignant où se diminuer en
envoyant son propre génie évolutif qui
est de l'ordre de trois à six mois
lorsque nous arriverons à la possibilité
de vacciner avec des nouveaux vaccins il
se peut que nous soyons dans une
nouvelle séquence
donc c'est où on part pour la
vaccination et on fait tout ce qu'il ya
à faire et je crois que là il faut
retourner à des textes européens pour le
combat là je suis d'accord et qui
existent aussi dans les textes français
celle usage compassionnel
lorsque l'on ne propose rien d'autre que
les vaccins faisons-le et avec un
maximum de sûreté bien évidemment on ne
fait pas ça n'importe comment mais on le
fait notre agence française de
l'estimation d'évaluation des
médicaments est quand même de haut
niveau c'est quelque chose qui est très
ancien même si elle a changé de nom
entre temps elle doit pouvoir nous dire
si c'est ification pas la littérature
est importante puisque ce vaccin et sur
le marché maintenant depuis début août
puisque l'été russes ont commencé début
août
beaucoup d'autres peuples entre autres
en amérique du sud on l'a dit tout à
l'heure mais maintenant aussi en europe
vaccine avec on à la littérature pour
dire si ça marche si ça marche pas bien
évidemment les effets secondaires ça
nous les apprendront sur un monsieur
nous n'avons pas l'antériorité
suffisante pour pouvoir dire donc
sortons effectivement de l'idéologie
allons officiellement vers la compassion
et permettons ces vaccins les plus
larges possibles et puis et puis on
n'essaiera tous s'en sortir comme ça le
mot de la fin pour vous fatima ya des
nids à clément bonin secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes ou dit
l'agencé européenne
a reçu le dossier de spoutnik il examine
les preuves scientifiques mans et le
validera cissé city anti fiq mans /
enjoint donc vous avez toute confiance
vous qui êtes docteur en virologie c'est
important de le souligner en l'ema moi
j'ai toute confiance en une agence que
je connais bien qui est l' agence du
médicament française et qui qui en fait
est d'une transparence puisqu'il suffit
d'aller sur leur site pour voir et les
études et les avis sur un certain nombre
et de médicaments et de vaccins et les
agences européennes alors en s'agissant
de ces vaccins en fait elle donne le
dossier à une à une des agences
nationales qui elle examine qui est le
rapporteur du dossier et qui en fait
examine le dossier le le dossier au pour
le vaccin
je ne sais pas quelle est la chance
nationale qui a en charge le vague
l'étude du vaccin ce pique nique mais il
est vrai que je ne peux que vous le
concéder que ça fait un peu tard de
déposer un dossier au mois de mars et
donne à voir la vie qu'au mois de juin
d'autant que comme vous l'avez tout dit
que là c'est une course contre la montre
et en tant que scientifique je ne peux
que reprendre vos propos en disant plus
on va vite et donc plus on diminue la
circulation du virus est moins on voit
l'apparition de variants et plus les
vaccins qui sont en cours sont permettre
une protection maximale est donc le
combat il est il est tous ensemble
contre ce virus et je crois que tout
tous les freins qui peuvent apparaître
doivent être levés et si malheureusement
il ya un frein du fait de l'origine de
ceux de ce vague de ce vaccin je crois
que c'est aux scientifiques de définir
qui les secure qu'il est viable et qui
peut permettre une protection maximale
et je pense que les politiques devraient
comme entière devrait résonner à bas
bruit parce que là le combat il est il
est tous ensemble pour éradiquer ce
virus parce que si on si on ne fait pas
collectivement on ne s'en sortira pas
merci en tout cas à toutes les 3g
leroyer
fait il maya dany et joëlle mélin
d'avoir été avec mon direct sur rt
france ce soir